l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 591 de Madame Élisabeth
Lamure transmise à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur vous avez la parole ma
collègue chers collègue merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre ma
question en effet porte sur la loi du 17
mai 2013 relative plus particulièrement
à l'élection des conseillers municipaux
et communautaires ou son article 34
semble poser des difficultés dans son
application alors cet article traite des
modalités applicables aux OPC à
fiscalité propres créées par fusion au
1er janvier 2014 et il prévoit ainsi que
le mandat des délégués des communes
désignées pour sierger au sein des EPCI
ayant fusionné et proroger jusqu'à
l'installation de l'organe délibérant de
l'EPCI issue de la fusion donc dans
cette hypothèse durant la phase
transitoire qui courent du 1er janvier
2014 jusqu'à l'installation du futur
conseil communautaire qui sera
issu des prochaines élections et bien la
présidence du nouvel EPCI issue de la
fusion est assurée par le président de
l'EPCI comptant le plus grand nombre
d'habitants parmi les EPCI ayant
fusionné
en premier lieu le président de ce
conseil communautaire de transition et
bien désigné de plein droit par
l'article 34 4 mais le texte ne précise
pas si le mandat des autres instances
exécutives des anciens EPCI fusionnés
c'est-à-dire vice-président et bureau en
tant qu'instance délibérante est
également prorogée avec les délégations
de pouvoir ou de signatures afférentes
ou si le conseil communautaire de
transition peut dès sa première réunion
procéder à l'élection de nouveaux
vice-présidents et d'un nouveau bureau
et consentir des délégations
d'attribution aux intéressés dans les
conditions qui sont prévues par le Code
général des collectivités territoriales
en deuxième lieu s'agissant des élus
composant l'assemblée transitoire dont
le mandat est prorogé la question est de
savoir s'ils peuvent continuer de
bénéficier des indemnités de fonction
qu'il percevaient avant la fusion au
sein de l'europeci respectif que ce soit
au titre de leur fonction de président
vice-président ou conseiller ou si au
contraire il est nécessaire que
l'assemblée transitoire délibère sur
l'octroi de nouvelles indemnités de
fonction aux élus concernées pour
l'exercice effectif d'édits fonctions en
troisième lieu l'article 34 5 énonce que
les pouvoirs du président de cette
assemblée transitoire sont limitées aux
actes d'administration conservatoire et
urgentes sans préciser si cette
limitation s'applique également au
pouvoir de l'Assemblée transitoire ce
qui soulève une interrogation juridique
de principe dans la mesure où par
définition c'est le président qui est
seul compétent pour établir l'ordre du
jour et convoquer les membres du conseil
communautaire en conséquence il y aurait
lieu de préciser l'étendue des pouvoirs
des volumes à l'Assemblée pendant cette
période transitoire et notamment si le
conseil communautaire peut adopter les
actes suivants le budget qui doit être
voté dans les trois mois les trois
premiers mois de la création d'un EPCI
l'institution de l'atome qui doit être
votée avant le 15 janvier de l'année qui
suit la fusion et enfin l'élection des
représentants de la communauté
d'agglomération dans les organismes
extérieurs donc compte tenu des enjeux
juridiques qui sont induits par ces
différentes questions je vous remercie
madame la ministre de bien vouloir me
préciser ces différents points
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
vous interrogez le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur la gouvernance
transitoire des établissements publics
de coopération intercommunale issue
d'une fusion manuel va se regrette de ne
pouvoir être présent parmi nous ce matin
il tenait à vous communiquer cependant
les éléments de réponse suivant vous
l'avez rappelé l'article 34 de la loi du
17 mai 2013 relative à l'élection des
conseillers départementaux des
conseillers municipaux et des
conseillers communautaires et modifiant
le calendrier électoral
issus d'un amendement parlementaire a
créé un dispositif dérogatoire au droit
commun ne concernant que les procédures
de fusion dès ce pays pardon à fiscalité
propre aboutissant au 1er janvier 2014
le deuxième alinéa de cet article
prévoit qu'à défaut d'applications
anticipée des règles de composition des
conseils communautaires de l'article L
52 11 6 1 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales le mandat
des délégués communautaires les EPCI
fusionner au 1er janvier 2014 et
proroger jusqu'à l'installation de
l'organe délibérant
issus de l'élection de mars 2014 ce même
article prévoit dans ce cas que la
présidence qui est au même titre que les
vice-présidents une fonction et non un
mandat est assurée pour cette période
transitoire par le président de l'EPCI
comptant le plus grand nombre
d'habitants parmi les EPCI fusionnés en
revanche aucune disposition ne permet de
maintenir dans leurs fonctions les
membres des bureaux des EPCI fusionnés
et ainsi de déroger à l'article
l521110 du CGCT qui limite notamment le
nombre de vices présidents
le conseil communautaire de l'EPCI
issu de la fusion doit donc désigner ses
vice-présidents ils exerceront leur
fonction uniquement pour la période
transitoire aucune disposition n'exclut
en revanche la possibilité de redésigner
les vice-présidents des EPCI ayant
fusionné
conformément aux disposition du régime
indemnitaire des élus locaux l'organe
délibérant du nouvel EPCI fusionné
installée pour la période transitoire
doit délibérer sur le régime
indemnitaire des membres du conseil de
l'EPCI les élus ne peuvent continuer à
bénéficier du régime indemnitaire acquis
au titre du président EPCI concernant
les pouvoirs de cette organe libérant
transitoire ni l'article 34 de la loi du
17 mai ni aucune disposition ne limite
les pouvoirs de ce conseil communautaire
transitoire qui dispose juridiquement de
la plénitude de ses pouvoirs le
législateur a ainsi précisé que cet
organe délibérant avait la faculté de
statuer dès le premier janvier 2014 date
effective de son installation sur la
restitution aux communes membres des
compétences qui lui ont transféré à
titre exceptionnel pardon à titre
optionnel
il réside il résulte également des
travaux parlementaires qui n'existent en
droit aucun obstacle à ce que les
délégués communautaires appelés assiégés
à compter du 1er janvier 2014 puisse
engager le débat d'orientation
budgétaire délibérée sur certaines
mesures fiscales et désignées des
représentants pour siéger dans des
organismes extérieurs en revanche le
président de l'EPCI fusionné voici
pouvoir limiter à l'adoption des actes
d'administration conservatoire et
urgente merci Madame la Ministre madame
Lamure souhaitez-vous réagir
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous avions pensé d'une manière
très simple que la fusion des EPCI
entraînerait également les la fusion de
l'ensemble des des délégations des élus
précédents alors on voit que cette un
peu moins simple et qu'il faut en effet
délibéré pour désigner à la fois les
vice-présidents et les responsables du
nouvel exécutif donc je l'ai bien noté
j'ai bien noté aussi que nous devions
s'il n'y a pas de prorogation de date
votez le budget dans les trois mois qui
vont suivre l'installation de ce conseil
transitoire donc je vais transmettre à
mes collègues qui sont nombreux dans les
EPCI qui ont choisi cette période
dérogatoire vous êtes possibilité
dérogatoire de conseils transitoire je
vais donc leur transmettre les éléments
que vous venez de me communiquer je vous
en remercie
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
la question orale numéro 567 de Madame
Françoise Ferrat à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ma question porte
sur l'avancement du projet de rénovation
du commissariat de police dépernaient
dans la Marne